[Musique]
la police passera dès demain vérifier si
les résidents bien des papiers en règle
faux et usage et où leur fille j'ai dit
si tu es les amener au religieux sûr
ma pelouse
salueront allez on y va on y va faites
comme chez vous ça fait des cafés mais
on débarque pas chez les gens comme ça
chez les gentils parce que là on est
chez les gens pardon pas au jeu je
croyais que j'étais chez mon meilleur
ami
les invités tous dans certains villages
on n'hésite pas andy des flics chez les
personnes qui viennent en aide aux
réfugiés
c'est rien c'est une descente de police
mais naturellement qu'ils peuvent dormir
ici on va pas les laisser dehors voilà
this is berthe welcome entame bientôt
nos jeunes n'ont pas touché verboten à
aarberg verboten
le cateau très bon et que tout ça est
immortel qui va m'apprendre comment ça
marche un tracteur
où tout est toujours une blague pour des
rires aux cellules ou sérieux alors
c'est entre 25 et 100 ans
takero tu vois rien j'ai grandi ici
pendant l'hiver
si un jour tu as un cadavre a planqué
j'espère c'est à moi que tu viendras
demander de l'aide
si un jour j'ai un cadavre à planquer ce
sera le tien
faut vraiment être con pour prendre la
vie au sérieux
[Rires]
[Musique]